aquí en mariupol el ruido de los
bombardeos no cesan alrededor de las
calles desiertas se encuentran miles de
edificios ahora destruidos
este hombre arrastra tras de sí un
carrito con todas las posesiones que
logró salvar todo nuestro
ya no tengo casa
fue destruida por los bombardeos
varias imágenes crudas surgen de este
puerto en ruinas los ataques uno tras
otro se han registrado aquí al igual que
en este edificio residencial donde los
bomberos tuvieron que sacar a esta mujer
de los escombros aquí los habitantes de
la zona hacen fila para recibir una gota
de agua
ya no tenemos agua potable en nuestros
apartamentos solo hacen diez o doce
grados no tenemos gas hace mucho frío no
hay nada que comer los cuerpos están
enterrados en los jardines de los
edificios es aterrador no podemos vivir
así
según el ministerio de asuntos
exteriores de ucrania en los últimos 12
días más de 1.500 civiles mariupol
fueron asesinados las organizaciones de
ayuda temen que se produzca una
catástrofe humanitaria si la situación
empeora